there's a lot of conversations at the
moment around concerns for the um
average amount of testosterone that men
have got
estrogens in the water and
stuff like that
should we be worried how worried should
it be
so um i just recently came back from
copenhagen i was there to give a talk
for the lunbeck foundation and there was
another talk that the lundbeck
foundation put on they do a great
popular science series um
called coffee and cocktails i'm not a
drinker but people it's so european it's
so different than over here was
everybody smoking outside no one was
smoking but people would bring were
allowed to bring in real glasses with
ice in them and yet the auditorium was
silent this was a big con it's in the
concert hall and copenhagen it's a very
beautiful venue and you couldn't hear an
ice cube [ __ ] the entire night no clean
clink clink no no chinking of the ice
cubes people were in there with their
cocktails and enjoying enjoying science
and earlier that week there was a talk
by dr shayna swann she wrote a book
called countdown
she went on joe rogan's podcast i
believe earlier last year
she talked about
the decline of sperm counts from the
1930s until now and
ties it in a very she's a serious
researcher with national institutes of
health grants etc ties this to
the increasing presence of phthalates
the most difficult word to pronounce in
the english language besides
ophthalmology
phthalates
that are present mainly present mainly
in pesticides if you look at sperm
counts and testosterone levels in males
in different areas of the united states
they are
significantly lower in areas where
there's a lot of pesticide use in rural
areas where there's a lot of farming and
pesticides
very serious issue and in the offspring
of mothers that
ingest
phthalates
there's this the anogenital distance is
what they study in the lab
the anode general distance literally the
distance between the base of the scrotum
and the um and the anus in males is much
greater than it is in
females there's a word for that females
don't have a scrotum obviously so they
measure from the base of the genitals to
the base of the vagina to the to the
anus in males they go from the base of
the scrotum depends on the study
sometimes it's the top of the scrotum
you know i always say you know you
always have to be careful when people
are measuring anything related genitalia
because somebody's going to cheat in the
measurement so
so in any event i don't know how they
controlled for that but she shows these
remarkable pictures in mice and in
humans of people that are exposed or
mice that are exposed to phthalates and
basically males are showing the more
female-like pattern
of of inner general distance when
they're exposed to the phthalate in
utero okay this is not post birth this
is in utero the mother's being exposed
it crosses the blood placental barrier
what's happening well this is reducing
sperm counts now what can people do
about this
well first of all there's this question
of whether or not phthalates are having
a similar effect after a child is
brought into the world
one doesn't know but we do know and this
is goes back to my early graduate work
was on the effects of androgens like
testosterone and dht on
different traits of brain and body
we know that
for instance it just very briefly that
during pregnancy the brain is organized
male by way of believe it or not
testosterone converted to estrogen
through a process called aromatization
but
the growth of the penis the fact that
there even will be a penis etc is set by
a
testosterone called dht
dihydrotestosterone
testosterone converted dht through five
alpha ductase and no no not
that's an organizing effect on the
system as they call it but then there's
an activating effect where during
puberty the testes just start producing
testosterone some is converted to dht
and the dht is what creates the growth
of the penis okay
in people that inject phthalates during
puberty and in the post-puberty years
it's conceivable that those phthalates
could inhibit the activating effects of
androgens not just what we call the
organizing effects of androgens early in
life okay why is this interesting and
important well sperm counts are
definitely going down are they going
down so much so that
people are incapable of reproducing
probably not because you know as they
told us in school it just takes one and
indeed it just takes one sperm but it is
a probability it's a numbers game right
the reason you know i people that take
anabolic steroids unless they
do things to offset the effect on their
own testosterone and sperm production
sperm counts are down so the probability
of
of successful insemination is of of the
egg is reduced also it's a numbers game
so it just takes one but having many
improves the probability that the one
will be able to fertilize
so the short answer is yes i think it is
very concerning now which things should
we be concerned about my understanding
of the literature and here i'm not
i'm now venturing into territory for
which i am certainly not an expert is
that things like plastics that have bpas
may be a concern drinking water may be a
concern but the most serious
or
enriched source of bpas are things like
printed receipts
yeah i was out for dinner the other
night it was probably about a month and
a half ago and the server came over and
i reached for the receipt and as i was
going for it like this one of the girls
who had never met before she's a creator
online
hit my hand away are you really going to
touch that
and this is the first time i've ever
heard about this this is legit yeah
printed receipts are are a
a rich source of bpas and topically that
could come through yeah it could go
transdermally i mean now you'd probably
have to handle a lot of receipts i mean
i don't think you're going to hear a
check out cashier perhaps this check out
the thing definitely check out cashiers
and listen it it's going to vary some
people are operating with a testosterone
level and sperm count that's already
back on its heels so to speak some
people have abundant testosterone and
sperm so
it's really going to depend on the
individual i don't think people should
get paranoid or delusional about any of
this but just don't start sleeping in a
bed of receipts don't start sleeping in
a bed of receipts that's an interesting
there are all sorts of jokes that could
be made about that one um that i won't
make but
there are also some other things like
you know do a little bit of online
research about phthalates and don't go
to fringe sites go to dr shayna swan's
website right i believe she's out mount
sinai or one of the other larger medical
schools in new york go to her website
she's a legitimate researcher and see
what's there see what the source of
phthalates are pesticides does that mean
you should only eat organic fruits and
vegetables maybe i don't know which
pesticides people are using on which
fruits and vegetables right so there's
some research that needs to be done
but
the moment we start talking this way and
people start saying oh wow this is
really like hippie science this isn't
hippie science this is
serious nih-funded researcher saying
phthalates before birth can dramatically
alter the trajectory of of the male
stability and make sperm and
testosterone
phthalates in puberty may be able to do
that but we know that that androgens in
particular dht and testosterone
converted to estrogen have a powerful
role in masculinizing the brain and body
during those years
why wouldn't people be
you know do half an hour of research
online or for instance the abundant data
that melatonin suppresses pregnant
excuse me suppresses puberty and yet
people will take melatonin like it was
you know insane
physiological levels
am i saying melatonin is going to
suppress your puberty if you took it as
a kid you're messed up no and yet it's
very easy to replace it with some of the
healthier alternatives that are out
there so i think that one can have a
thoughtfulness about this stuff and some
and it's action oriented without having
to really freak out about it what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace